Así va llegando más y más gente al
obelisco de Buenos Aires se van
acercando una marea de gente a celebrar
el triunfo de la selección argentina un
triunfo que costó que se hizo rodar que
hizo mucho sufrir pero que también para
muchos ha sido muy importante tres
partos tuve tres partos y nunca en mi
vida sufrí lo que sufrió hoy fue
terrible fue terrible este partido pero
Carolina valió la pena cada instante
estoy quemada pero amo amo mi país estoy
orgullosa y se dedico a mi familia Los
amo me estoy enfermo No tengo voz y para
mí es un día muy especial Porque es el
aniversario de la muerte de mi viejo
enfermo jugador de fútbol y nada no
podía ser de otra manera es la única
manera de reivindicar esta fecha de
Leonel Gracias visita el día más
feliz de mi vida y así sigue llegando
más y más gente a celebrar seguramente
hasta la noche durante la noche y
esperar la llegada de la selección este
lunes para celebrar para recibirlos para
festejar con ellos en Buenos Aires